now speaking of relationships
speaking of relationships this is a
story that that hits very close to home
oh boy this is an interesting story and
one of the most public relationships
ever
right and now they're going through a
divorce
of course i'm talking about
kim and kanye
this is our other wild there they are
money story of the week
right such a unique couple what a unique
couple so it's it's it's been called the
biggest ass
versus the biggest [ __ ]
in history a lot of ass going on over
here yeah so but ironically the divorce
has been
very civilized and smooth
um probably the smoothest of their
entire relationship yeah ironically
today of all days is
kim k's birthday so happy birthday to
kim k yeah
you know i've spent a lot of time with
kemp oh well
wait a minute we'll get into this that's
so true she did marry one of my best
friends you i was a groomsman in the uh
her previous wedding that's so and the
last time that we spoke her and i
physically spoke i was like well i'm
sorry that it didn't work out you know
i've spent a year literally staying at
her house like going on vacations with
her groom's been at her wedding walked
chloe down the aisle like i was in there
i was in the family i was like sorry for
over a year sorry it didn't work out
yeah um what are you doing what are you
doing later thank you let's go
she compared herself
to elizabeth taylor now if you
understand what that means elizabeth
taylor i think i believe was married
eight times
kim just finished her third or fourth
wedding meaning there's more coming
sauce get in line bro what we'll see
yeah
either way
either way with all that being said
kim kim yay kim and kanye
they're done
they're done
um i don't care why i don't care what
happened are you surprised i'm not
surprised
uh i don't care about the details but
what i do care about yeah i'm interested
in this headline is the money yeah what
the hell's going on with all this money
kim kardashian wins big and divorced
from kanye west yes that sucks there
they are that sucks for kanye let's see
what's going on so uh ironically you
would think
all right
hollywood marriage disaster here we go
yeah crazy lawsuits no
they actually were
financially smart and they had a plan in
place okay aka chris jenner was like
look i don't see this marriage lasting
five more than five years so
let's get this [ __ ] prenup signed and
that's exactly what happened they had a
prenup in place it spelled everything
out basically the prenup said what's
mine is mine is what yours is yours i
keep my stuff you keep your stuff and
then the court will decide upon the rest
and i'm not talking about
court like kourtney kardashian if you
saw that clip on snl where it was like
the people's court yeah k-o-u-r-t it was
a great clip yeah um i'm talking about
the court the court system the law
breaking the law i was just thinking of
that so tell us what we can learn from
this power couple yeah well
for our viewers getting divorced what
can they learn
i don't think you're divorcing well
prenup that's number one yeah um well
here's let's break down some of the
numbers that's been going on here in
case you're interested in the prenup no
no no they had a prenup okay so they did
have getting ready that's my point go go
they the the prenup basically said
what's mine is mine which is yours you
keep your stuff i keep my stuff oh i'm
sorry and then the court will decide
what's next okay they had a prenup in
place they were smart of course so
basically the big one
was the 60 million
dollar
estate that they were living in they
raised all their kids in yeah uh in uh
calabasas i believe hollywood hills area
hidden hills estate
um
60 million kim got that
kim was awarded the 60 million dollar
house now just to put it in perspective
this is how much real estate has grown
over the last
seven years yeah this 15 000 square foot
house that they bought in 2014 you know
how much it was worth when they bought
it in 2014. how much 20 million
now it's 60 million seven years later
yuks yeah talk about la real estate
unbelievable yeah i mean now i mean just
by them buying it it goes up because
it's true this is the house this is the
house
this is where they live with all the
kids this is where it was
so kim got the house 60 million but
kanye is now crashing
at his bachelor pad it's 11 million
dollar ranch in wyoming i hope he's like
all right he's going to be okay he just
came out with the donda album today i
literally think today or the day before
he changed his name officially to yay
just why e all right pete did he yeah
well he has changed his name a gazillion
times yeah diddy puff daddy
dizzle dizzle i don't know i just made
that one up but anyway he's connie is
crashing at his 11 million dollar house
in wyoming it's currently on the market
11 million bucks
uh but according to tmz
yay
formerly kanye he had just purchased a
57 million dollar beach house in malibu
for the sole purpose of being close to
his kids that's a good dad
57 million dollars yeah it wasn't like
an apartment for like 100k or something
not never kanye so kim got the 60
million dollar house the estate kanye's
crashing his wyoming ranch and then he
just bought a 57 million dollar beach
house in malibu but then they've got
uh we're gonna break down their net
worth for sure but there's there's 70
million dollars in joint assets
ass as i see what you do there's a
little thing right there
um that they need to break down one
being a 14 million dollar miami condo
okay i'll take that off their hands if
they look yeah dude it's fine david you
like to live there it's not a big deal
if i have to do if we have to all right
there's five million dollars in art four
million dollars in vehicles three
million dollars in jewelry and get this
300 grand of livestock pardon in wyoming
they're just just they got they got
livestock
to get some cattle
so uh the assumption is that they're
going to split it equally do you know
how much each of these guys are worth by
the way god i don't know so when you're
when they're divvying up
you know the condo here or the estate
here or the five million dollars in art
or four million dollars of vehicles or
the cattle
uh just just think about um
that kanye
if he's not the most he's he's certainly
in the top two or three yeah richest
black men in us top three for sure for
sure he's a billionaire yeah kanye is
currently worth
1.8 billion dollars holy
and there's speculation that it might be
more than that i'm sure there's
speculation that might be less 100 more
than that
but it's not all liquid it's not a
liquid with kanye because it's mostly
tied up in his
yeezy brand clothing brand with adidas
he's got a big stake in gap
i think like a billion of the 1.8 is in
illiquid assets
tied up in the company okay okay
um
the good thing about kanye is he owns a
hundred percent of his shoe brand the
adidas yeezy you know how much yeezys
are i think they're like 200 bucks a
pocket 250 whatever here they have a
weirder shape to them okay you ever had
a yeezy no no i'm a i'm a
new balance adidas vans type of dude you
ever had a cheesy pardon it's like a
budget yeezy
ghetto off of wish yeah
so basically he's got the business model
going on respect to him he collects a
quote unquote 11 percent of yeezy's
annual revenue which is about 1.3
billion in 2019. so 10 of 1.3 billion
that's 130 yeah million dollars kanye's
doing all right this is why he can be
like look
take the 60 million dollar house that's
fine
i'll live in the ranch i'll buy another
50-something million dollar house and
malibu will figure it out
kim you know i think kim just um
hosted snl she did a great job i think
kanye did show you see what kanye is
wearing where's the most ridiculous
masks ever you see what he's wearing now
he usually wears a face mask a hoodie
yeah but now he's wearing like look up
kanye west's
mask
face mask
um so let me know when you pull that up
but either way
kanye west face mask
yeah there it is oh go to images oh my
oh he's always doing some [ __ ] like this
is this what you're talking about no
there's a weirder one but they're all
weird they're all weird this is what he
wears like for the piano
go back um go back to the search
okay
i know what you're you're referencing go
back to the uh
this one
this one this face this is like a
creepy prosthetic caucasian mask for cab
ride from jfk there he is oh that's so
weird that's actually
it's like you're like i'm actually into
it yeah that's kind of bad anyway kanye
invisible man with uh what's his name
okay well kanye i mean
jesus walks
stronger
uh graduation
things fall down
diamonds are forever i mean the list the
hits go on and on like
say what you want about kanye
um
the dude makes music musical genius yeah
[ __ ]
don't get me started on the musical
genius thing i think he is i think the
musical genius the dude makes hits i'm
sorry don't
okay he's a great musician you like that
no
i think look i respect him as a
businessman i think he makes obviously
hits i mean i'm no [ __ ] okay but like i
think genius gets thrown around a little
uh he's a liberal genius would you put
musical genius would you put him next to
[ __ ] beethoven would you put him next
like is that the same ranking yeah i'd
rather you know am i you know what i'm
saying like [ __ ] was death 700 years
ago
regardless respect to kanye he's you
know whatever he's doing his thing just
giving his album let's talk about kim
for a second kim
kim is now officially a billionaire now
she's a musical genius
[Laughter]
probably the least talented billionaire
ever you do it
i mean
i want to see your her talent is looking
good sex tape yeah um
[Music]
she's doing her thing anyway she's worth
currently 1.2 billion dollars right how
much was honey 1.8
so
uh
you know she's bringing home the bacon
so anyway she's more liquid she's got
250 million dollars in cash and other
investments on hand
right so the bulk of kim k's fortune
uh i believe is tied up in her cosmetics
company the kkw beauty forbes estimated
that kim's has a 72 percent stake in the
business worth 500 million of that kim's
a billionaire connie's a billionaire
they're doing billionaire things they're
splitting assets they got 50 plus
million dollar houses
they got cattle they got jewelry they
got cars
money cash clothes money cash clothes
like they got it all you know what they
don't have what don't they have
stability in their marriage they don't
have stability privacy yeah that's true
i get to go home and be nobody i'm
nobody i got your face but what can we
learn from all this what can we learn
from all this uh it's fair to say i
think kim turns now i think 41.
um
kanye's 44.
they got a long life ahead bro 44. yeah
they got a long life ahead
they are what is called chillin do you
have a do you have a whose side are you
on
in this marriage
in the divorce i mean are you like i'm
on team kanye
does it even matter no i could give a
[ __ ] about it okay they're billionaires
here's what i can tell you here's what i
can tell you you know who's calling the
shots and all this kim
no huh kris jenner oh the momager chris
how could i she's pulling all the
strings
she
leaked the sex tape
she
encouraged kim to marry chris back in
the day the big e wedding hollywood true
hollywood romance
she set it all up with kanye kanye's
mom's part of like a just a contract it
might be like you'll be married for x
amount of years you'll do this and this
will come out of that
who knows
but um interesting this is happening
they're all gonna they're you know
they're both billionaires but this is
where we're at in our life is that is
that dope rappers become billionaires
and
influencers
become billionaires so why because she
built her personal brand off the
kardashian keep it up with the
kardashians so what can the luis alphas
the young johns the david parras of the
world learn from uh i'll tell you what
this divorce
start rapping
you have two options don't start
wrapping you have two options you start
wrapping
you start making shoes and clothes
you put out a sex tape
oh my god you get some ass injections i
don't know what to tell you
maybe i don't know if there's no there's
nothing we're going to learn this is
just celebrity profiles there's nothing
we're going to learn from this marriage
hopefully your your marriage lasts
forever
uh i can guarantee you this kim is going
to be married a few more times her words
to my ears
i envision myself as the modern day
elizabeth taylor elizabeth taylor do the
math
married eight times
kim's working on number four right now
that means that's how by the 100th
episode i'll be a millionaire
boom we just figured it out see this
brainstorming session guys episode 100
david's actually not here he's over with
the kardashians with kim
i will say that i've kicked it with her
a bunch yeah sweet girl uh it's just
it's a different life over there bro
you're living the hollywood life
um
you ain't ready if you're if you're not
ready for all that
i will say that um look at look at
everyone who's coming to that kardashian
life i'll look at all the men in that
world yeah i'm ready the father i'll do
it yeah okay i'm just saying just real
quick robert kardashian the father yeah
dead okay okay bruce jenner
woman
robert kardashian has never seen these
days never
um lamar odium odom married to chloe
crackhead
almost died he's
scott disick my dude i've had great
times with scott rehab hopefully he's
figuring it out that's my guy
um
who else is in there in that family
the
what's his the other the brother
rob i said he's
like a recluse
the women run the show in that family
your boy yeah he got out
my boy got out
kanye's getting out um
travis scott
and now devin booker so it seems to be
the the younger
are doing all right the the travis
scott's in the world so you're saying
there's a change saying there's a chance
anyway let's move on here shout out to
kanye shout out to kim for having an
amicable divorce show showing us how
divorces should be done talk is money
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken